Dieses Foto ist wirklich mehr als eindrucksvoll:
Die Rede ist von der NASA-Aufnahme eines fast
perfekt rechteckigen Eisberges.
Fotografiert wurde das mysteriöse Objekt
im antarktischen Weddell-Meer während eines
Forschungs-Fluges.
Seitdem rätseln das ganze Netz, was dahinter
steckt.
Und der Klischee-Eisberg ist nicht die einzige
ungewöhnliche Entdeckung der NASA in der
jüngsten Zeit, die so perfekt geometrisch
ist.
Wie diese Formen zustande kommen und wer wohl
dafür verantwortlich ist -Clixoom Science
& Fiction Hier gibt es täglich unglaubliche
Science-Videos Abonniert den Kanal, damit
ihr keins verpasst herzlich willkommen!
Dieser Eisberg sieht viel zu symmetrisch aus,
um wahr zu sein, oder?
Wurde er etwa künstlich zugeschnitten oder
aber die Aufnahme im Nachhinein einfach mit
Photoshop bearbeitet?
Fest steht aber: Der Eisberg sieht zwar unnatürlich
aus, ist aber echt und zwar tatsächlich in
dieser gigantischen Form eines Müsliriegels!
Entdeckt wurde der außergewöhnliche Eisberg
bei dem NASA-Forschungsprojekt namens “Operation
IceBridge”.
Hierbei sollen die Veränderungen der Eisverhältnisse
in den Polarregionen dokumentiert werden.
Eine Mitarbeiterin der NASA beschreibt den
mysteriösen Eisberg im Weddell-Meer vor der
Antarktis als “ungewöhnliches Exemplar,
das fast wie ein perfekter Quader” aussieht.
Zu erkennen sind die scharfen Winkel und eine
flache Oberfläche.
Bislang gingen die Forschungsteams deswegen
davon aus, dass der Eisberg gerade frisch
von der Front des Larsen-C-Schelfeises an
der Ostküste der Antarktischen Halbküste
abgebrochen sein muss.
Doch jetzt gibt es neue Erkenntnisse dazu:
Der eckige Tafeleisberg ist offensichtlich
schon im November 2017 abgebrochen.
Entstanden ist er wohl kurz nach dem Abbruch
des gigantischen A68-Eisbergs vom Larsen-C-Schelfeis.
Seine Vorläufer sind auf Satellitenbildern
zu erkennen, die zu diesem Zeitpunkt aufgenommen
worden sind: zwei frisch gekalbte Eisberge:
Neben einem gebogenen Eisstück eben auch
ein relativ rechteckiger Eisberg.
Dieser hat wohl seitdem schon eine sehr lange
Reise hinter sich.
Seit Ende 2017 trieb er langsam nach Norden
und stieß immer wieder mit Eisstücken zusammen.
Unter anderem gelang er auch durch eine richtige
Gefahrenzone hindurch.
Nämlich eine Engstelle mit felsigen Vorsprüngen,
die von Experten auch als “Nussknacker”
bezeichnet wird.
Denn Eisberge, die hier hindurch treiben,
bleiben meistens nicht unbeschadet.
So auch der Vorläufer des mysteriösen Rechteck-Eisberges,
der zerbricht.
So entstehen einige geometrisch geformte Bruchstücke.
Darunter eben auch unser Rechteck-Eisberg.
Fachleute bezeichnen solche Objekte als sogenannte
“Tafeleisberge”.
Solche langen und flachen Eisberge bilden
sich, indem sie sich eben von den Schelfeis-Rändern
abspalten.
Laut der NASA ist die Entstehung solcher Tafeleisberge
mit einem Fingernagel zu vergleichen, der
zu lange wächst und letztendlich dann abbricht.
Solche Tafeleisberge sind übrigens eher typisch
für die Antarktis.
Die Eisberge, die wir beispielsweise vom Film
“Titanic” im Kopf haben, laufen nach oben
spitz zu und sind dagegen charakteristisch
für die Arktis.
Die Bildung von Tafeleisbergen ist tatsächlich
ein natürliches Phänomen, doch wir berichten
hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction ja immer
wieder darüber: Laut Studien schmilzt das
Eis in der Antarktis immer schneller und das
rapide Abbrechen großer Flächen vom Schelfeis
wird wohl vom Klimawandel begünstigt.
Das Krasse an dem jetzt entdeckten Exemplar:
Die NASA-Aufnahme zeigt wohl nur etwa zehn
Prozent des Eisberges - etwa 900 Meter breit
und 1500 Meter lang!
Der Rest befindet sich unter dem Meeresspiegel
und ist dort wohl wahrscheinlich längst nicht
mehr so rechtwinklig und kantig.
Mittlerweile hat sich der Eisberg weiter nach
Norden ins offene Wasser bewegt und wird wohl
irgendwann tauen.
Und ich hatte es schon kurz erwähnt: Dieser
außergewöhnliche Eisberg ist nicht die einzige
kuriose Entdeckung der jüngsten Zeit.
Mitte Oktober hatte ein NASA-Forschungsteam
eine weitere mysteriöse geometrische Form
entdeckt und auch fotografiert: Ein angenagtes
Dreieck nämlich das an ein Stück Pizza erinnert.
Den Link zum Pizzaeisberg findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung.
Wenn ihr garantiert kein Video bei Clixoom
verpassen wollt, dann abonniert Clixoom auf
englisch hier, einfach draufklicken, denn
da gibt es auch Videopremieren, wie zum Beispiel
erst letzte Woche das Interview mit Havard-Professor
Abraham Loeb zum Thema: Ist Oumumua eine Aliensonde.
Hier geht es weiter mit “ Competition for
Elon Musk: "Flying Trains" from China” Wir
sehen uns auf dem englische Kanal von Clixoom
Stay tuned and see you soon!